Nikos Psaltopoulos, Thank you so much
for joining me all the way from Australia.
How are you doing?
Hey, Michael, really good.
It's really good to see you.
Really good to see you.
Really good to see you too.
How have you been doing this covid?
And you're originally from Greece
now, you're in Australia.
What's happening with you?
It's a bit mixed up, I know.
But we can get there.
So, I started off from here actually.
I'm Melbourne born and raised.
And I moved across to Greece
about three or four years ago now
to do some work with MarineTraffic.
And I came here back to Australia
in Feb.
But I've been locked in
with the lock down ever since.
So, I'm not going anywhere in a hurry.
And look, I'm happy to be back here.
It's a great country,
as you can appreciate.
And I just work remotely.
So, we're making it work.
I love it. I love it.
Okay. Great.
So, over these next 20 minutes,
I'm really excited to talk
about a variety of things
that we've already started discussing
before we started sharing this episode,
about this idea
of dealing through adversity,
leading through crisis.
Particularly, also, what you're doing
with marine traffic.
So, Nikos, I'd love for you
to tell me a little bit
about where you started.
Where your journey took you.
And then we'll transition
off to the entrepreneurial stuff.
Done. Done.
So, I started off doing media.
I'm a journalist by trade.
And I always wanted to be a journo.
And I worked in the media at a time when,
believe it or not,
the Internet was just amazing.
So, we were starting to see back then,
the impact that the Internet
would have on our economy.
Let's pick up exactly where we left off.
So, take me back through your journey
and then we'll transition
to MarineTraffic.
Sure. Always
I've got to say,
it was poetic watching you
walk into the sunset over the bridge there
as you went off towards the alarm.
It was amazing.
It was a beautiful moment.
Okay. So, I started off in the media.
And I work in the media
for about five years.
And it was an amazing experience.
Because I got to cover lots of stories
and really interact with people
from all walks of life.
But it was at a time when,
believe it or not,
the Internet was just starting
to have on media.
It was in the late '90s.
And you could see the landscape
changing very very quickly.
So, I want to do something different.
And one thing I learned very early on
is our ability to be relevant
depends on our ability
to disrupt ourselves.
So, the more often
we can disrupt our own trajectory,
that ensures greater relevance
in the world and the space
that we find ourselves in.
So, when I wrapped up with media,
I fell into pharmaceuticals.
And I spent 15 years
in the world of Pharma
working for an American
multinational company based in Chicago.
And they were absolutely brilliant.
So, I worked in leadership in pharma
and really understanding
how to build a business,
how to engage with customers,
strategy, marketing,
all the great things
that they get to learn
from a multinational group
like a huge pharma company.
In the last five years
of my time in pharma,
what I could see, though,
was big corporate business
and the way that it was structured
versus this ecosystem
that was emerging around the world.
This ecosystem that was very
innovative and disruptive.
And I had a really good energy about it.
And almost like an attitude of
anything is possible.
Just watch us and we'll make it happen.
And I was really really attracted to that.
Because what I found was
working for a big company
as good as it was in the initial stages,
that it was slow to move.
And we weren't actually responding,
but we were reacting to change.
And that was a real problem,
as we know now.
So, what I did
in within the last five years,
I discovered co-working
when I was in New York.
I went into one of the original
WeWork spaces in downtown New York.
There's a story there.
And I thought,
"Great, I could do this in Australia."
So, I launched a couple of
co-working spaces in Australia.
Here in Melbourne.
Yeah. There were very in demand.
So, it was designed to be
quite collaborative.
But what it did as we manage these spaces,
and these spaces grew.
It exposed me to this
it was almost like I was falling
into this black hole of wonderland
of all these startups and tech
and bloggers and vloggers,
and you name it.
People earning income and making a living
in a very different way
to what I had been trained
or accustomed to doing.
And, you know, Michael,
it really excited me and it enthused me.
So, I did that for the last five years.
And obviously that got me
into all these startup events.
I became an ambassador
for the startup, Grind.
And continue throwing myself
into the startup community.
Understanding how it worked
and the opportunity
that existed in the world
that was changing super super fast.
And all I knew was that
I didn't want to miss out.
I wanted to be part of the change.
I wanted to be part of the world.
I didn't want to be irrelevant.
And not being irrelevant meant,
constantly getting out of my comfort zone
to learn new things and challenge myself
and feel uncomfortable
more so often than not.
Wow. Okay.
So, you're starting off
all the way in media.
You're finding yourself
in pharmaceuticals,
in a big company realizing that
there's all these great changes
and a big company might be
maybe slow to move.
And you've transition all of a sudden
to co-working spaces
and starting co-working spaces
in Australia.
And you're getting exposed
to all these startups.
So far, correct?
So far, [--]
Startup grind, and now you realize,
okay, your passion lies
in seeing these changes unfold,
dealing through these adversities
and discovering new realms.
How do you find yourself then
in marine technology in MarineTraffic?
Yeah, it's crazy.
It's been an amazing ride.
So, I did brief stint
with the health tech startup
here in Melbourne.
And whilst I was doing that,
I was given the chance to do
head of sales innovation role
for a fashion brand,
which I've never done before.
And it was an amazing experience.
But when I left that,
I started my own consultancy.
I really wanted
to do something for myself.
And whilst travelling, being lucky enough
to travel around the world.
Remember these things called aeroplanes
that we can't get into anymore?
I used to basically live and work.
I got to meet the CEO of MarineTraffic.
To be honest, the time I didn't know
a lot about the company.
I had a really good friend of mine
he works in the organization.
And he did say to me this,
"You guys need to get together."
"Because I could see so many commonalities
between the two of you."
And we did get together.
And we had an amazing conversation.
And that conversation spurred some work
that I did for MarineTraffic
as an independent consultant.
And then that resulted with the role
that I'm currently doing now.
And I'm just so super humbled
to be able to support
an ever growing team
in maritime technology.
And the fact that it's a startup
that emanated from Greece.
At a time when Greece
was in financial turmoil.
I think that in itself
is an amazing story.
Wow. Okay.
So, I hear a lot
about non-linear trajectories
and non-linear paths to career.
I don't know if I've heard
as many that come close
to what you're describing here.
Now, talk to me a little bit
about maritime technology,
marine technology.
And Greece during the economic crisis.
I'm assuming that you're talking about
looking at 2008 onwards.
And what's happening
with marine technology?
And why are you excited about that now?
So, super excited.
It's an amazing space
like when you consider that 80 to 85%
of all the goods around us
have been transported to us
by a shipping.
Then you quickly understand
the level of depth that shipping has
and the important role that it plays
in our lives.
So, that was one thing.
The technology itself.
Then I learned about the story
of MarineTraffic.
And it started off as a passion project
by our founder, Dimitris Lekkas.
And he's a professor
at Aegean University.
And what he did was
he created the global community,
a global community
of shipping enthusiast.
And what he did, he sent out AIs
transport this around the world
where people place them
in strategic positions.
And then we picked up data.
And that data now became the platform
that is known as MarineTraffic.
Providing different layers of information
to people from all walks of life
every single day.
And critical information.
As we saw the other night
with the explosion in Beirut, in Lebanon.
It was MarineTraffic data
that was able to actually piece together
the journey of the ship
that had the components
that caused the explosion.
So, shipping technology
touches on many different parts.
It's the retrospective data that we have.
But it's also the data
that can improve efficiency
in shipping full stop.
And that's really really exciting.
So, are these cases mainly focused
on efficiency and optimization?
Or more about security and knowledge?
Where does the big value lie
in having this data?
All of the above.
Because it's different strokes
for different folks.
And different companies and businesses
have very different needs.
So, we've got to understand that
when it comes to shipping,
it's an industry that for many many years
was actually untouched by technology.
So, the progress that we had seen
in other spaces
didn't exist in this space.
So, all of a sudden,
you've had this massive investment
in shipping technology
that has really changed the way
shipping is and will be forever.
And that's really exciting
to be able to be part of that.
Now, when you're saying
shipping technology,
I'm assuming it's not necessarily
that the ships are changing,
but it's about
how do we monitor these ships.
How do we optimize the space
that we store on these ships.
And how do we decide
which ship takes where,
and what journey they do, right?
Michael, it's a bit of both as well.
Because not only do we have
shipping intelligence
that actually gives us
different layers of data
as to how shipping operates
around the world.
But we're also at the day and age now,
where we're looking at
autonomous shipping.
Shipping without anyone
just basically carrying cargo
around the world.
So, exciting times
that we're living through.
Wait. Are there literally ships
with autonomous ships
that have nobody on them right now?
Yes. So, in testing, yeah.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
It just dawned on me
that this term shipping,
we use it interchangeably now
with any good that is being transferred
from one place to another.
Or we want to ship a product.
But I guess it stems from the fact that
everything is done by ships, right?
You're saying 80 or 85% of the things
are actually done by ships.
So, it's now making a lot of sense.
So, it sounds like
we are in this exciting time
where maritime technology
is becoming more and more relevant
and more startups are going into it.
It sounds to me pretty obvious
that if 80 or 85% of goods
are transferred through ships,
this should have been
one of the first industries
to be able to utilize big data.
But it sounds like
that wasn't necessarily the case.
There weren't many entrepreneurs
going into that field in the first place.
And that's a really good point.
I think maybe there was an eagerness
for entrepreneurs to break in.
But like any industry,
when an industry set in its ways,
it's really hot and it's working,
and it's working for the people
and the key players in that industry,
it's really hard
to really drive the change.
But at some point
something starts to break.
And when it starts to break,
and it's not working as efficiently
as it once did,
that's the catalyst for change.
So, it is probably almost like
a perfect storm at once we know
it was a product market fit
where something wasn't working
and it became apparent.
Then all of a sudden,
the need for technology in this case
became more real, more relevant.
Wow. Okay.
So, now talk to me a little bit
about dealing with adversity
and dealing with difficulties,
especially through covid.
We mentioned this before,
but I'd love to hear a little bit
about your take
in your leadership journey there.
Okay. It's been an amazing journey
for everyone in the last few months.
And who knows what happens next.
And up until now, though,
as an organization, as a team,
I've got to say,
I'm really proud of the way
we and our team have managed through this
over the last few months.
It's been incredible.
One thing that we did was
it was quite prophetic, actually,
in January, every January,
we have our kickoff summits.
So, we fly in our team
from all over the world
into the heart of Athens
and we have a kick start
to the strategy, marketing,
and time for us to bond and get together.
Wow.
During the last day of this team meeting
that we run, we had a pandemic.
We had H1N1 breakout.
So, about 10 of that team members
got sick during this process.
So, what we then did was in January now,
we have to lock down our offices
to revert obviously the spread.
Now, that was basically a practice run
for what was to come only
like a month and a half later.
And because we were following
the situation from Wuhan,
we're keeping a very close eye
on the situation.
When we could see things
at the tipping point,
just before they took over,
We called it.
So, we actually shut our offices down
very very quickly.
We communicated with our team very openly.
And we sent everyone home
as the dispersed team
to work from wherever that leads
anywhere in the world.
And I think taking action early on
and being on top of it
was really really important.
Particularly because
it's such an unknown, scary situation.
The next thing we did, Michael,
was we called fortnightly meetings.
Which we still do.
We called it routine check ins.
And it's a chance to just get together.
And at times it may not be
anything new to say,
but the fact that we're together
and see each other on screen
and we have a bit of a laugh,
a bit of banter
is really really important.
Because they're the water cooler
conversations that we can no longer
physically have together.
And it's not until
you connect with the team
the way you do remotely,
that you really understand and feel
how much the people that you work with
really mean to you.
And what massive role they play
in each of our lives.
So, having a meetings fortnightly
with the global team
was really really important.
Very quickly as well,
we also from the crisis management team.
And the crisis management team,
which I'm part of as well,
was all about
assessing the situation on a weekly basis.
What are the hotspots.
What are we doing.
What are scenarios
that we should be exploring.
In the scenario planning,
it was really really important
that we kept it very simple.
Because this can play out
in so many different ways.
You get super confusing.
So, we only ever focused
on one, two or three scenarios, max.
And we're usually pretty much
in the right area.
But fundamentally,
apart from all the logistical stuff,
the most important thing
that we were doing
was maintaining human connection.
Maintaining connection through dialogue.
Through conversation.
Through Slack.
Through phone calls
that we have with that team.
Or through Google Hangouts discussions.
And that one on ones.
And maintaining that
even to this day and beyond.
It's something we will continue to do.
It's really really important.
Because people work with people.
People connect with people.
And we as humans give each other
greater purpose and focus.
So, ensuring that people
are feeling safe and secure.
[--]
Huge priorities for us.
But maintaining this,
being able to look at people
and see how they're feeling
and ask them questions
beyond the questions and all that
was super important
and has been a saving grace.
It hasn't been easy.
Because even leaders
have their moments as well.
And I read somewhere recently that
the role of leader in the crisis
is to absorb fear and exude hope.
And I really really believe that.
At times, though, even the leader,
can be a little bit shaken.
And I think it's really important
for everyone to hear that
and understand that.
Because at times,
and I'm guilty of that too,
we may put unrealistic expectations
on our leaders
and what our leaders should be doing next,
and what they should know,
and what we expect of them.
And if this situation teaches us anything,
it should teach us a shift in mindset.
A mindset that is more humanistic,
more centralized on heartset
and mindset and connection,
rather than ego and me.
More about we than me.
I love it. That's just incredible.
By the way, how did the team react
when already a month before
the rest of the world,
you're shutting down?
Essentially, you're doing something
that even in March,
I remember that when I left
Stanford campus in mid-March
and we said,
"Okay. We're coming back in a week or two
after spring break."
And then they said,
"No. You're not."
We were like,
"Wow. This is this is crazy."
"We can't even believe it."
I can only imagine the reaction
that people might have had
back in February or January,
when you're making these decisions.
When the world is still not talking
about covid-19, right?
Well, and maybe I misled you.
So, what we did was
we shut down in January
on the back about our own pandemic
of H1N1 infection within our company.
So, we shut down for about
a week and a half,
but then we really opened.
So, when we monitor the situation
and we could see things
moving very very quickly,
we were able to quickly shut down again
for the second time.
This time because of covid.
Not because of H1N1.
Okay. So, you had that experience
and you were able then
to adapt quickly.
And the team members
already knew the protocol.
So, it was a little bit less
of a shock factor
than perhaps for others.
Moving forward, I mean,
what do you see happening
both with your organization,
but overall in the world
of technology and tech
as you're experiencing it?
Obviously you're in the forefront
as a leader.
Leading a team through this crisis.
You obviously have to prepare now
for years to come,
both in terms of work from home,
but also in terms of
running a company in this new mindset.
So, how are you even approaching this?
Look, that's a really good question.
And it's a very interesting situation
that we all face.
And it's interesting because, Michael,
like we've been accustomed
to instant gratification.
There's a problem. Let's fix it.
We're back to normal.
And I know people
don't want to hear the term,
but we're entering the unknown.
and that's the new normal.
The new normal is to totally expect
the unexpected.
And I think about generations before us
who've gone through real hardship,
through wars, through famine,
through difficult life changing events.
And what those events
taught them at the time
was resilience.
And the power to be able
to have a sense of perspective
and move on step by step.
Our generation right here, right now,
we want instant gratification.
Okay, covid. Let's get over it.
Let's move on.
Let's get back to how we were.
Firstly, I think
that's a waste of a crisis.
A total waste of the crisis.
If we're yearning to go back
to what we were,
I could think of nothing worse.
Like, we've learned something.
We've gained something.
So, let's redesign it.
Let's rethink it.
Let's move on to something
that could be better than what it was.
But it's human nature
to feel safe and secure.
To gravitate to what makes us
feel safe and secure.
And that is the past.
But in this case, we need to let it go.
Because, as you said,
and I totally agree with you,
what we're experiencing
is not going to last for a few months.
It will last for a number of years
if we're lucky, if we're lucky.
So, what do I think will happen?
When you consider the mumps,
And a funny thing, that mumps,
it took them four years
to develop the vaccine
for it to go to market.
And that was the whole world
working together
to actually develop a vaccine.
Now, that was in the '60s.
Admittedly, we've moved on
in leaps and bounds
in terms of tech and science and pharma
since then, I get it.
But we still need to go
through four phases of trials,
which includes human testing
at the end of it
before we even have a vaccine.
So, let's not wait
for that silver bullet to come.
Instead, let's redesign our own pathway.
So, companies like Google and Uber,
as we know, have already announced
a work remote plan
at least until June, July 2021.
So, firstly, I think it's really important
to be able to give your team, a company,
a bit of a timeline.
A bit of an understanding that,
"Hey, this isn't going to be
quickly fixed."
"That we're going to need time."
"And in that time,
all we can ask is a constant flow
of open and honest,
transparent communication."
People feel unsafe.
People lose their balance
when the communication stops.
And even if there's nothing new to say,
like I said earlier,
there's nothing new to say,
maintaining that communication
is really important.
So, for us, we have a plan
over the next few months.
And what we're doing,
we're monitoring the situation
that I mentioned earlier.
And in September, we're getting together
a crisis management team,
and we'll assess the situation at the time
to make a decision
as to what we need to do
between September and December.
Having said that, our summit for 2021,
is in January again,
and it'll probably be virtual.
So, we're planning a virtual summit
and we're excited to be doing that.
But you know what?
There's opportunity in that.
Because we've reached out
to some amazing global speakers
that ordinarily,
we would not have access to.
So there's always new opportunity.
Now, the other thing
that I just want to mention
is the mental health challenge
that we all face
during this time of quarantine
and isolation,
feeling the way that we're feeling.
One of the things that we did
very early on this year
is we employ a full time psychologist
in our team.
Really?
Yeah. And she's an MT coach.
And every single one of our team members
has unlimited access to our MT coach
whenever he or she need to have a chat.
Whether it's personal,
or professional.
She's there. We're there to help together
with our people operations.
That's just remarkable.
I just, I'm so inspired
by your take on it.
And the excitement that you're bringing
to the table with this change and saying,
"Yes, we have this issue
that we don't know what's happening."
"It's really problematic."
"But we're extremely excited about
the different opportunities
that it present and we're always looking
at the upside of it."
So, I think that's just
a remarkable way to go.
And I can only imagine
that everybody who works with you
in this company,
can only feel the same excitement
for dealing with this adversity
and dealing with the challenges.
And the fact that I agree
that knowing the timeline
and having these expectations.
And already planning
a virtual summit for next year,
I'm sure that it gives
some sort of confidence
to the team that saying,
"Well, we know some things."
"We don't know a lot of things."
"But our leadership is guiding us
towards some reality
that we can be confident."
And I think that's wonderful.
Nikos, before we leave,
I have to ask you
for my favorite question.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Sure, Done. All right.
Okay. I think first and foremost,
empathetic.
I feel joy, I feel pain.
I feel what you're feeling.
And that gives me
a real heightened sense of experience.
And I love that
because it really aides with connection.
So, definitely empathetic.
I'm super super curious.
I always want to learn and throw myself
into the most challenging situations.
People who know me very well go like,
"You're crazy. You're crazy."
"How can you do that?"
But I do it.
I do it because I'm curious.
And I think that also leads
into being adventurous.
I love adventure.
I love throwing myself into a plane
and going to countries
that I've never been to before.
Not knowing a single soul
and then walking away
with amazing best mates with me for life.
So, I think those three words
to describe me.
Nikos, thank you very very much.
This was inspiring.
I enjoyed it so so much.
Best of luck with everything.
And I look forward
to continue watching the company grow
and watching
your non-linear career proceed.
Because it just it's remarkable.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Michael.
Thank you.
Take care.